make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are picking up with house of
X part 5 and this is actually one of the
coolest things because like a lot of
crazy things happen in this and
everything changes in its entirety right
so like I just really kind of dive right
into this so what we do here is we
initially pick up with Lorna Dane and
with Magneto now the cool thing about
this is that remember where Lorna dana
is exceedingly powerful and she behaves
the powers of magneto for all intents
and purposes there is still a lot of
learning that goes on there with her
insofar as the world of Magneto plays
and how kokoa works and all that kind of
cool stuff and so sort of hashing this
wisdom on is a bit of a cool thing
because what she what is it happening is
she asked the question is there any good
to humanity and magneto responds to this
by saying well there was a point when
Humanity was composed of hunters and
gatherers right it was a nomadic setup
where humans would just travel from one
place to the next they would basically
forage for food or resources or
what-have-you and then move on to the
next it wasn't until humanity started
settling near bodies of water and then
started forming civilizations around
those bodies of water and then expanding
in an outward direction that they
basically created society and in doing
that they of course pass that on to
mutant kind not in a literal sense but
in the sense that mutant kind could
basically follow the path of humanity
and find a refuge unto itself ideally
the island of Crick howa so again like
it's kind of interesting here because
what is up happening is you basically
have what's what's called the coming
together of the five and it's a really
cool concept because what this means is
there are five mutants that have been
brought here selectively by Charles
Xavier himself and the reason is because
they serve five particular purposes the
first person here is Fabio Matt Medina
now fabula Deena was a character or is a
character rather who creates these kind
of like golden balls which nobody ever
really seemed to care about what you end
up finding out is they were actually
eggs now what Hickman doesn't explain
here is if these eggs are created and if
these eggs are planted somewhere will
they just state given enough time or are
they simply unfertilized eggs right well
they did sort of wither and die and go
away as if they're never fertilized at
all will they just sit there for all
time waiting to be fertilized we're not
really given an answer to that question
but it's kind of cool because we don't
need one
instead we're basically giving this
scenario to where you have you have
Proteus the son of more McTaggart who
can again manipulate reality in a
localized space right we've made videos
about and we've talked about him so
you'll find those down in the
description but using the reality
warping abilities of Proteus and then
using you know some of the preserved DNA
which we'll talk about that here in a
second as well as using a lick sir who
can basically give life what this
is it allows them to in turn use the
powers of evil to manipulate time and
then speed up the gestation process and
essentially create new mutants now this
is one of the reasons why reading
everything that Hickman does is
exceedingly important because when you
look at this you say okay well where'd
they get the DNA from we got that last
little tidbit from the last comic right
we're like Charles Xavier basically
asked mr. sinister to create a giant
repository of mutant DNA this is why so
that at a future point in time he could
start resurrecting x-men and that's
basically what he does he recreates all
the x-men who died on the facility on
the satellite during their initial
launch now it may seem kind of like a
hand wavy thing and a way to just to
kind of be like whatever you know and
just kind of like bring a character back
from the dead in a really convenient
manner right I mean some people will
look at it that way
Hickman is never that way right this is
designed to introduce a concept this is
designed to introduce a way in which a
mutant can return and do it in a fashion
to where it'll become exceedingly
important later on down the lock right
so to degree it is a bit hand wavy but
it is also one of those moments where
you have to keep this in the back of
your head because if you don't then
you'll basically get lost in the shuffle
in however long it takes for Hickman to
get around to it during dawn of X but
it's kind of a cool little thing because
following that what we also get is his
explanation about cerebro and over the
year cerebro had always been build in
mobile comics as this device that was
developed through accommodation of
Charles Xavier and Magneto and so on
that would allow him to find any mutant
around the world
what cerebro can actually do is has
basically been copying the mental
patterns of of x-men all across the
entirety of its existence right and so
what this does is it allows the DNA as
it was kept by mr. sinister to resurrect
the physical bodies of the x-men and
then in turn the information stored of
cerebro allows them to basically
reinstall the the mind so to speak of
the person who was created right now
again this is not Hickman making this up
we saw this happen in the Iron Man
comics you know so we've seen this
happen a multitude of times over the
years of Marvel Comics whereby a
person's mind can be more or less backed
up and when that person dies if they're
recreated their mind can be reinstalled
back into their brain and they'll go
back as they normally would right
they'll go back completely functioning
as it was kind of a cool thing because
what you get here is the return of all
these x-men who died right you get the
return of Wolverine you get the return
of Nightcrawler of Jean Grey of Cyclops
all these carriages Monet's st. Croix
the whole nine yards all these
characters that died have all basically
been brought back and
was one of these cool things because
storm basically goes out there and
speaks to the people of cacoa on behalf
of Xavier magneto on all them and says
like these people have been recreated
and I know there's some degree of
distrust right you don't know if it's
truly them you know it's a mutant but
you don't know if it's truly them so let
me verify and by kind of going through
and testing each one they all pass in
the sense the Cyclops make four it makes
reference to I thought I knew what it
meant to be like a strong leader and
then you showed me that's a reference to
when Cyclops battled storm for
leadership of the x-men and storm one
and then Cyclops basically left so that
was back during the old Chris Claremont
and Lewis and Walter Simonson and Bob
Layton eras of uncanny x-men and
x-factor in turn you basically end up
getting like you know Jean Grey who's
tested here you have Monet st. Croix
who's tested she's kind of like get your
hands off me each one of these mutants
are individually tested each one of them
are tested in a way to verify that they
are who they they claim to be and it's
really it's really a way for Hickman to
tell us this is really them right it's
not just like duplicates or I guess it
is to a degree but they're not like
false it's not a false Cyclops right
it's not a fake mone st. Croix or fake
Jean Grey this is actually then this is
is really and truly them as it was kind
of a cool thing because where Xavier
would be excited about this and where he
would celebrate this moment the reality
is that they're all basically hinging on
a vote from the United Nations to decide
whether or not to secret kala as an
actual sovereign nation right like is it
its own Island like its own country
where only mutants for Zod now this is
an important theme because this magneto
basically pulling a bit of history out
of Marvel Comics and the reason why I
say that is that if you go back and you
read x-men vol 2 issue number 87 that
was a story whereby magneto basically
sees the magnetic poles of Earth and
then basically blackmailed humanity into
giving mutants their own island which of
course turned out to be Genosha and so
it's not the first time something like
this has happened and it's not hitman
just pulling things out of his backside
now there are vast differences between
Genosha and cacoa Riker Crowe is a
living Island Genosha was just a giant
chunk of land out there somewhere so
again there are big differences this
will be a far more safe place than
Genosha ever was but it is kind of a
cool moment here because what you end up
doing is getting into like the actual
day of the vote and it's kind of a
blessing but a curse at the same time
because the votes ultimately passed you
know like like you basically have kokoa
going forward as a nation the issue with
this and the way it worked was that Emma
Frost essentially swayed the vote using
her telepathic powers and Charles Xavier
basically says hey look we appreciate
everything you've done just know things
like this always come at a cost and
while it's it's not really
made clear by Jonathan Hickman what this
basically means is that somewhere along
the line someone's gonna realize
people's minds were tampered with
and while the vote has really just kind
of gone through and there's not much
they can do to undo it I guess they
could try to Jay could try to vote
against it you know what kind of ban
them you know take away their their
their nation but what that would do if
that were the case is it would lead to a
war between humans and mutants right
because it would basically be humanity
saying all right all you mutants to not
have a place of your own and it's saying
never mind no you don't and then taking
it back right so I mean you know here's
a safe haven never mind now you have to
flee For Your Lives all over again and
it just wouldn't work right and so what
this does with with United with the
kokoa now being listed as an actual
sanctuary a livable sanctuary an island
that's governed and occupied only by
mutants and the only people that can get
in that are non mutants are those that
mutants allowed to get in basically
brings in a whole host of different
people and so you've got mr. sinister
and his Marauders
you've got been a dupe Harry which is
actually really cool to see Exodus here
and you have apocalypse and this is one
of the coolest moments here because
apocalypse showing up is just kind of
like wow like this is this is Wow
because remember when it comes to
apocalypse outside of what we saw in
that that future conflict where he was
defeated by Nimrod which I still don't
agree with I still think apocalypse
could have defeated Nimrod I feel like
he should have I feel like Nimrod just
not powerful enough to defeat of
pocalypse that's me is the fan talking
with no factual evidence to back that up
outside of the powers of apocalypse has
but I feel like apocalypse should have
won that battle but but apocalypse
showing up here is a big thing because
we would expect him to show up and then
instigate conflict you know to test
those individuals who believe that
they're powerful enough what in reality
he's actually showing up here fairly
benign of course yes history with Kirk
oh we talked about that in the last
video and so he really shows us of this
island more as a friend and when he's
speaking with magneto and speaking with
Wolverine magneto says we need to hear
you say that basically you're not going
to cause trouble here because if you are
going to cause trouble then we'll kick
you out right well does have Cocola
banish you and it's kind of cool because
his response is no I'm not here to cause
problems you all turn out to be exactly
what I wanted you to be over the years
over my entire existence
I've pitted the weak against the strong
in an effort to eliminate the weak
they're like you guys in this point
right now have become the strong you've
literally moved away from the point
where you're falling prey to this
ideology of what we can help them see
the error of their ways we can if we're
nice enough we can get them to change
their minds right I mean that doesn't
work right i mean if you're nice enough
all you're gonna do is get caught and so
like like in this instance it's kind of
like you guys are finally woken
to the reality of the world that being
nice is just not the way that it works
right like the world's filled with nice
people and none of them ever really get
anything done right I mean it's all
those individuals who were willing to do
whatever needs to be done in order to
get things done that end up getting
things done and he's like do you've
woken up to this reality now like you've
woken up to the way things are to the
way the world is you have become what I
always wanted you to be you are now the
strong and so as a cool thing because
when he finally concedes and says from
this day forward I'm not apocalypse
standing alone I am part of you
basically up ha collapse joins the x-men
and it's the coolest thing ever because
what Xavier says is if that's the case
then welcome home with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here too comments
explained make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]